Corinne Peluchon vous êtes philosophe et
vous vous êtes très vite intéressé aux
questions de bioéthique d'écologie en
lien avec la philosophie politique vous
êtes d'autre part très engagés dans la
cause animale vous êtes d'ailleurs vegan
même si vous n'aimez pas trop qu'on le
dise ou en tout cas qu'on vous irezise
mais sans pour autant rejeter l'héritage
de la modernité et notamment des
lumières ce qui est pourtant la pente
naturelle de ce qu'on appelle les
abolitionnistes nous traversons une
crise majeure à tous les niveaux
climatiques mais aussi civilisationnel
précisément il est communément admis que
la crise est en grande partie le
résultat de cette modernité alors
comment concilier les lumières et ce que
vous vous appelez l'âge du vivant
qu'est-ce qu'on garde des lumières
qu'est-ce qu'on jette oui alors d'abord
je pense qu'on peut définir les lumières
qui est désigne moins un continent ou
une époque qu'une manière de regarder le
présent de façon critique donc en
identifiant ces défis et l'État
permettant de renouer le lien entre la
théorie la pratique et en ce sens les
lumières désignent toujours un processus
inachevé à reprendre à chaque époque
mais il y a quand même un socle de
principe qui définissent les lumières
contre leurs ennemis de toujours les
anti lumière ce socle de principe pour
être clair ou simple il se caractérise
par l'autonomie l'idée qu'on peut
prendre en main son destin le deuxième
principe c'est l'égalité donc une
société un ordre social et politique
fondé sur l'égalité des
êtres humains et le troisième c'est
l'unité du jour humain qui s'est traduit
entre autres par les droits de l'homme
et la quatrième idée ou le quatrième
principe c'est la rationalité la raison
comme
outil majeur pour s'émanciper et contre
cela s'oppose des anti lumière qui
veulent asseoir un ordre sur des
hiérarchies sur la théologie la religion
sur un essentialisme donc une différence
biologique entre les humains qui
justifieraient un assujettissement des
uns par les autres et qui sont dont et
les anti lumière se caractérisent aussi
par une haine de la raison qui est une
arme de guerre contre justement ce
projet d'émancipation alors moi je garde
ces principes et je pense qu'ils sont
très importants notamment aujourd'hui
parce que les anti lumière et bien se
manifeste un peu partout par le retour
des nationalismes par les politiques de
puissance d'Empire et de guerres etc
mais je crois effectivement que pour
maintenir ces quatre principes et
l'esprit des Lumières et peut-être les
prolonger puisqu'elles sont un héritage
inachevé il faut paradoxalement
critiquer leur fondement en particulier
le dualisme nature
la séparation radicale de l'humain avec
la nature et les autres vivants et donc
arracher comme on le fera d'une écharde
dans la chair le l'anthropocentrisme qui
est un point de vue étroit consistant à
considérer que l'humain est au centre et
que les autres êtres n'ont de valeur
qu'instrumentale je vous propose
d'écouter une archive de 1972 de
Lévi-Strauss
nous savons bien d'un côté que la
culture l'ensemble des croyances des
institutions des pratiques que les
hommes mettent en oeuvre dans leur vie
sociale que tout cela est une partie de
la nature et en même temps nous avons
intérêt au point de vue opérationnel je
dirais presque à faire comme si c'était
un règne un domaine complètement séparé
et j'imagine que vous êtes un petit peu
dans la même situation quand vous êtes
confronté à un problème comme celui du
rapport de la vie ou de la pensée
puisque la pensée c'est évidemment un
phénomène de la vie mais que d'un point
de vue pratique vous avez intérêt à
faire comme si la vie s'expliquait
intégralement par des principes ou des
considérations tout autre
vous les commentez alors d'abord je
voudrais dire mon admiration pour les
bistrots qui
disait d'anthropologie structurelle 2
que
l'humanisme qui était le nôtre était des
vergondés et assis sur un amour propre
c'est lié à cette séparation entre
l'humain et les autres vivants cette
manière de d'oublier que l'humain est
aussi un être vivant et cela ouvrait la
voix dit-il un cycle maudit et à
l'ensemble des discriminations dont le
20e siècle a été témoin et alors
aujourd'hui on repense un petit peu le
rapport nature existence vie il s'agit
pas de nier les différences humains
animaux il s'agit pas de lignée du tout
mais de comprendre ces lignes de
similitudes et de différence comme
disait Derrida qui est également est à
déconstruire l'humanisme classique et je
crois que aujourd'hui on a la chance une
certaine manière de repenser l'humain
sans être obsédé par un propre qui se
définit de manière toute façon élitiste
est très et réservé à quelques humains
c'est à dire que penser l'humain
seulement comme défini par la pensée et
même la pensée laquelle celle de
l'Occident c'est évidemment donner
prêter le flanc à une attitude et de nos
centrices qu'ils critiquera à une
attitude de mépris à l'égard des autres
vivants mais encore une fois je crois
que si on rétablit un peu les choses et
qu'on adopte un regard éloigné comme il
disait si on pense avec le voyage avec
les autres cultures et aussi les autres
vivants qu'il y a de multiples manières
de configurer le monde et de saisir le
sens et que les animaux par exemple
aussi sont des êtres intelligents disait
mon thème à la biologie vraiment c'est
bon les essais et bien alors s'enrichit
notre perception des choses nous rendant
à la fois plus humble et plus à l'aise
dans notre monde donc je crois que les
vistrauss c'est pour moi non pas une
critique seulement de l'humanisme passé
jamais l'occasion de penser un humanisme
différent de la différence de l'altérité
de la diversité oui parce que vous tenez
une position un peu similaire qui
consiste à la fois être antispéciste on
peut le dire peut-être pas
voilà non et en même temps humaniste qui
sont généralement d'opposition qui
s'opposent alors non vous les tenez
ensemble ah ben je pense que l'humanisme
c'est l'idée que pour protéger la nature
les animaux faut commencer par l'humain
c'est-à-dire repenser la manière dont
l'humain s'est conçu lui-même dans son
rapport à la nature dans son être à la
nature comme disait aussi Michel Serres
et dans ce rapport aux autres vivants
vous êtes beaucoup intéressé aux animaux
à la cause animale autant je pense dans
votre vie que dans votre philosophie en
quoi cette prise en compte de l'animal
vient faire bouger les lignes même d'un
point de vue méthodologique pourquoi
tout à coup la question animale vient
faire bouger toutes les lignes de la
pensée philosophique en tout cas en ce
qui vous concerne parce que c'est pas
juste un détail à l'intérieur ou une
région philosophie j'ai l'impression que
ça irriguait quand même une manière de
repenser le monde oui tout à fait
c'est-à-dire que d'abord quand on
s'interroge sur la vulnérabilité la
passivité du vivant il est difficile
d'oublier les animaux qui comme nous
sont mortels comme nous vulnérables
comme nous enfin froid et qui disait
mère le pontet de manière très belle
dans les années 48 on causerie il disait
qu'ils sont jetés dans un monde dont ils
n'ont pas la clé ce délire que ça ne
tombe pas tout cuit si je puis dire il y
a une précarité de l'existence animale
une inquiétude bon mais il y a aussi
c'est vrai que la question animale a un
caractère stratégique parce que nous
avons longtemps pensé l'humain ou plutôt
l'humanité en l'opposant à l'animalité
et se faisant nous définition les
animaux parce qu'il n'avait pas le Logos
langage articulé et
c'était une manière de les
simplifier ou de les rater même puisque
on gommait
et leur singularité ce sont toujours des
êtres individuelles il y a toujours
quelqu'un derrière la fourrure elle est
plumes et quelqu'un qui aussi nous
échappe qui certes à des normes
éthologiques des besoins de base liés à
son espèce mais qui a ces petites
préférences on a vu tout à l'heure votre
adorable chienne Manille et donc qui a
sa subjectivité même si c'est une
subjectivité ou une conscience non
représentationnelle elle ne se voit pas
vivre elle ne s'interroge pas sur sa
préférence entre quand ou égal mais elle
est c'est quelqu'un donc et c'est vrai
que à mesure que
les études du comportement des animaux
l'éthologie mais aussi la phénoménologie
enrichissait notre connaissance des
animaux de la complexité de leur vie
psychique de leurs besoins etc et bien
les frontières tracées entre les humains
et les animaux se brouillaient sans se
disparaître complètement et tout cela ne
conduit pas à mais au contraire à
réhausser sa responsabilité qui elle et
peut-être un propre de l'homme car et
les animaux ne sont pas coupables des
n'ont pas une intentionnalité comme la
nôtre et en tout cas on peut pas
reprocher retomber dans les procès des
animaux faisaient au Moyen-Âge ou quand
un sanglier faisait des dégâts sur dans
un jardin et bien on faisait un procès
non ça n'a pas de sens il y a pas de de
cette responsabilité là chez les animaux
donc il y a bien des différences mais
c'est vrai que la question animale elle
est stratégique parce que pour des
raisons de définition de nous-mêmes elle
est elle est centrale mais surtout je
dirais pour moi j'ai pris en compte le
fait que les traitements que nous
faisions subir aux animaux quasiment
dans toutes les activités pour l'élevage
pour la mode pour l'aspérermentation et
bien on disait long sur nous-mêmes
creuser les traits de notre donc le
projecteur n'était plus sur l'objet de
la morale mais sur nous-mêmes aussi et
justement les l'industrialisation de
l'élevage le nombre de vies sacrifiées
pour des plaisirs souvent substituables
et la manière dont ils sont élevés
aujourd'hui dans les élevages
industriels et bien tu es un coup de
projecteur sur ce que nous sommes
devenus au cours des siècles et sur ce
qu'un modèle de développement
aberrant et des humanisants a fait de
nous pour prendre en compte les animaux
dans nos vies et au cœur du politique
pour faire que leurs intérêts compte
malgré tout même si c'est ce sont les
humains qui en décident il y a toujours
cette asymétrie entre les animaux et
nous et bien pour arriver à faire cela
il faut se débarrasser de d'habitude
remettre en question bien des pratiques
par exemple la corrida aussi en ce
moment il faut aussi innover pour
apprendre à manger avec moins de viande
voire sans viande et donc c'est pour moi
c'est pour moi le faire de l'ange de ce
que j'appelle un progrès moral et majeur
donc c'est à la fois une approche
critique comme toujours avec la question
animale
et c'est une approche constructive car
elle est aussi même dans son pathos
puisque être s'intéresser aux animaux
aussi souffrir de ce qu'on leur fait
souffrir la souffrance des bêtes mais
elle est aussi porteuse d'un projet très
stimulant
je reprends le terme de stratégie que
vous avez utilisé qui a une stratégie
philosophique méthodologique mais qui
peut également devenir une stratégie
politique où est-ce qu'on constitue par
rapport à cette question est-ce que
est-ce que la crise écologique est-ce
que le traitement fait aux animaux à
travers l'industrie animale contrainte
philosophe à devenir militant quels sont
les quels sont les postes comment on se
distribue soi-même dans ces différentes
fonctions de citoyens de chercheurs de
Phil alors moi j'aime pas trop le mot
militant parce que le philosophe doute
le philosophe est là pour mettre de la
perplexité sur le monde et son rapport
au monde tout en étant engagé et est un
engagement indirect si j'ose dire cercle
la valeur ajoutée du travail
philosophique n'est pas d'aller défiler
avec des pancartes mais elle est de
prendre du recul et elle est aussi de
penser contre soi-même et en particulier
quand on est philosophe politique
puisque on peut être pur dans sa cuisine
mais dès lors qu'il s'agit de penser des
normes pouvant être universalisables ou
instituer le bien commun toujours à
définir et à redéfinir dans une
démocratie qui par définition l'Institut
de manière non définitive et bien il
faut aussi tenir compte des personnes
qui pensent différemment et des intérêts
divergents ou alors on abandonne la
démocratie ce qui pour moi et pour vous
et impossible et surtout pas souhaitable
donc du coup il y a là à essayer de
construire des accords sur fond le nom
des accords et néanmoins il faut bien
avoir un certain courage politique pour
dire qu'il y a certaines choses qu'on ne
va plus faire c'est comme ça que des
progrès sont advenus il y a eu abolition
de la peine de mort en 81 parce que on
avait jugé que la peine de mort était
mauvaise et en plus c'était
contre-productive permettait pas de
baisser la criminalité etc je reprendrai
pas les arguments de Badinter ton
discours est à l'Assemblée formidable
mais je dirais que là il y a un courage
politique à voir donc il s'agit de
tracer
une de voir quelle pratique peuvent être
aujourd'hui abolies car elles ne sont
plus soutenues par la population ne sont
plus utiles sont même nuisibles à
l'écologie à la vie sociale etc comme
élevage industriel mais comme aussi
beaucoup de pratiques mutilante pour les
animaux il peut y avoir même des
élevages assez industriels sans les
mutilations des cochons sans la
castration à vif etc et des pays qui le
font qui légèrent pour ça et puis quelle
pratique
euh sans être aboli tout de suite
peuvent être modifiées avec des
aménagements donc dans le manifeste
animalise un troisième partie j'avais
dressé une liste des propositions qu'on
pouvait faire et surtout des moyens de
le faire parce qu'on ne peut pas
supprimer certains métiers par exemple
de dresseurs de fauve dans les cirques
animaux sauvages et les bêtes au chômage
du jour au lendemain il y a l'idée d'une
reconversion il y a aussi le respect de
l'identité de ces personnes qui s'est
construite dans ces métiers etc donc là
aussi vous voyez le philosophe c'est
quand même quelqu'un qui aime la
complexité en tout cas qui qui doit la
l'assumer et donc quand il s'agit de
donner quelques idées ou quelques gari
de quelques principes qui pourraient
permettre
d'astituer le bien commun sur un sujet
non seulement il est bon qu'ils
connaissent le terrain et les
difficultés
rencontrées mais il est bon aussi et
surtout il est nécessaire qu'il pense
aussi contre lui-même
pour essayer trouver quelque chose de
valide de manière on va dire pas
universelle mais quand même général et
ça c'est c'est ça alors que le militant
les militants moi j'ai rencontré
plusieurs militants animalistes
écologistes ou aussi quand je
travaillais avec des associations de
protection des malades
usagers d'hôpitaux Alzheimer ils ont des
niches c'est-à-dire que le l'animalisme
s'intéressera pas tellement
malade d'Alzheimer malade d'Alzheimer
s'intéressera pas l'animaliste etc
philosophe il travaille et souvent aussi
contre lui-même voilà parce que la donc
je crois que c'est pour ça que le
rapport du philosophe aux politiques et
même aux militants ou à la cité comme
disait les Vosges trop il est toujours
en tension une tension qui qui est
intéressante qui est mais il y a jamais
de confusion et voilà alors moi et puis
en plus il y a rien de plus anti
philosophique que l'idéologie puisque et
en même temps vous dites aussi d'une
certaine manière que la radicalité fait
bouger les nu-politiques donc on est oui
chez les militants ça c'est clair qu'on
peut on peut parfois être agacé par des
militants mais si on se rappelle ce que
disait Serge Moscovici qui a travaillé
sous luminorité active il distinguait
les minorités des minorités actives qui
ont un impact par le fait que celle-ci
souvent était en rupture avec les normes
et il le faisait de manière très
cohérente mais parfois c'est disons
musclé et sans violence mais disons de
manière
n'hésitez pas à afficher leur
hétérodoxie comme il disait élégamment
et que c'est ça qui faisait bouger les
lignes et effectivement
souvent les changements sociaux ne
s'opèrent pas par les arguments sinon ça
se saurait mais par justement ces
mouvements et au niveau inconscient
c'est-à-dire que il est vrai que depuis
quelques années on peut on peut toujours
critiquer certains associations
protection animale 214 mais n'empêche
que enfin moi je les critique pas je les
aime beaucoup évidemment mais je trouve
que ce qu'ils ont réussi à faire c'est
quand même si tout le monde n'a pas
vocation et de venir vegan tout le monde
s'interroge aujourd'hui en tout cas
beaucoup sur la provenance de la viande
et que même ceux qui sont pas d'accord
avec ces militants sont amenés voir
contraints sont contraint de se poser
cette question et ça je crois que c'est
important les toutes façons il y a pas
de changement sociaux sans une certaine
turbulence
et je crois que la démocratie n'en
déplaise à ceux qui aiment beaucoup
l'ordre et un moment il faut de l'ordre
quand on Institut des lois etc la
démocratie est toujours un peu sauvage
puisqu'elle redéfinit le bien commun et
avec des enjeux nouveaux et en même
temps donc du coup après il s'agit
d'encadrer la conflictualité non pas le
si opposé mais pas non plus confondre
conflictualité et violence
violence verbale physique ni tyrannie du
bien donc ça c'est la démocratie suppose
tellement de maturité tellement de
qualité qui sont pas seulement
intellectuelles mais capacité à vivre
ensemble de te dire dans cette
conflictualité ça demande tellement et
c'est vrai que notre époque aime bien
les clivage les réflexes identitaires et
de la philosophie comme la démocratie
qui se ressemblent tant qui sont nés au
même endroit disait Castoriadis
propose justement
cette cette ouverture de pas avoir ces
réflexes
identitaires et ça c'est je crois que
c'est peut-être la chose du monde la
moins bien partagée aujourd'hui
alors justement quel est le rôle selon
vous du philosophe dans la cité alors
vous y avez un petit peu répandu mais on
a coutume de dire enfin en tout cas dans
l'histoire de la philosophie la tantôt
était roi la tantôt au contraire ermite
en dehors de la de la cité parfois
conseiller du prince vous le verriez où
dans la mêlée démocratique alors on
flexualité
même si les embrasses parfois
mais je dirais que le philosophe sa
valeur ajoutée c'est cette
c'est cette instabilité j'allais dire ou
plutôt le fait qu'il n'est pas
identifié à cette fonction-là de
conseiller du prince ou de roi
d'ailleurs ça se passe en général très
mal quand il est conseillé du prince on
Platon était vendu comme esclave etc et
puis
dermite oui il y a elle sert que la
distance du philosophe sont détachement
se fait pour un engagement et son
engagement est et inséparable d'un
certain détachement donc il y a un
engagement indirect mais quand même le
philosophe je crois il est là pour
peut-être non seulement donner un esprit
critique aux gens des outils pour mieux
penser le monde mais moi je dirais
qu'aujourd'hui ou le lien entre la
théorie pratique a été brisé notamment
après la fin des grandes idéologies des
grandes utopies politiques je crois
qu'il est important que au lieu de voir
de manière surplombante les choses et de
donner des leçons de morale il a
beaucoup qui le font et bien il s'agit
peut-être d'accompagner d'avoir un
regard sensible sur ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui et d'être capable
d'accompagner des mouvements qui
existent
en mettant des liens entre le vivant et
les morts le passé le présent sans
penser qu'on va tout changer du jour au
lendemain mais en essayant de voir dans
le passé ceux qui peuvent nous éclairer
les philosophes ou les autres qui
peuvent nous éclairer et en voyant aussi
ce qui change où sont les les où sont
les les défis
et d'accompagner un mouvement justement
en lui donnant une cohérence donc moi je
crois que c'est pour ça que c'est une
rationalité sensible
qui il s'agit de parler au monde et pas
seulement sur lui et ça c'est peut-être
quelque chose qui demande de l'empathie
et d'aucune philosophie de professeur ne
suffit pas moi plus va sans doute est-ce
parce que je vieillis plus je me rends
compte que mon expérience petite soit
elle inspire beaucoup de mes thèmes et
sans doute
explique une certaine attention vivant
la vulnérabilité mais aussi
explique
l'acceptation d'un vertige au cœur de
mes plus grandes convictions qui donc
qui les renverse donc vous êtes toujours
en dialogue avec vous-même comme le veut
la définition platonicienne finalement
de la pensée
peut-être parfois un peu contre moi
vous êtes une démocratie à vous toute
seule la conflictualité non parce que la
concerne Rico était répond à ces
questions de soi-même comme un autre
tienne dialectique entre soi et soi
entre soi et idem les repères qu'on a et
qui souvent volent en éclat à l'occasion
de crieres personnelles et lipser
c'est-à-dire ce qu'on est soi-même et
qu'on définit un certain autre niveau et
souvent
de manière fragile
forte et fragile à la fois qui se
définit par ceux en quoi on croit
l'attestation dont il rappelle
l'étymologie enfin le lien en allemand
baie de soyoum avec ça
donc conviction donc il y a et puis il y
a quand même la dialectique entre moi et
autrui les grandes souffrances viennent
quand même des autres les remises en
question les plus dures viennent quand
même des autres
et de soi mais aussi des autres et puis
les normes il y a toujours une tension
entre
exigences ou le rêve de vie bonne et
puis la nécessité de vivre en société et
l'obéissance aux normes donc c'est il y
a quand même ces trois tensions ça fait
beaucoup pour une seule personne pour
chacun d'entre nous ce qui fait que la
vie est sans cesse une reconstruction
alors exercice difficile est-ce que vous
pourriez définir la grande question
philosophique d'aujourd'hui
et bien justement je dirais que c'est le
progrès parce que c'est une notion
qui ne fait pas qui ne séduit pas grand
monde aujourd'hui on comprend pourquoi
puisqu'il y a plein de phénomènes de
régression tant au niveau social
politique au niveau des mœurs dans
certains pays et puis aussi évidemment
les technologies
parfois enfin souvent nous échappe ont
des des conséquences etc et néanmoins
moi je ne veux pas l'abandonner même au
singulier puisque des progrès en âme le
progrès mais je veux pas l'abandonner
mais je dirais comme Adorno le progrès
commence là où il se termine c'est à
dire qu'il faut en finir avec certains
credos qui
identifiez le progrès à la croissance
illimitée ça s'est terminé mais le
progrès moi je crois justement que au
cœur même d'une conscience tragique
d'une conscience
aiguë de la possibilité de notre la
possibilité de la possibilité de
l'effondrement qui est pas seulement lié
au réchauffement climatique qui n'accuse
pas seulement une souligne pas seulement
notre vulnérabilité mais celle aussi de
notes civilisation au cœur même de ce
qui est presque un désespoir il y a
peut-être en tout cas oui il y a la
possibilité de penser un âge du vivant
ou en tout cas des signes avant-coureurs
d'un âge qui pourrait réenclencher un
processus civilisationnel et qui
s'appuierait sur justement la prise en
compte de notre finitude de notre
vulnérabilité par une révolution
anthropologique mais qui est liée un
projet politique où on habite la terre
autrement où on en finit avec cette
prédation et cette domination mais je
crois que on peut et peut-être on doit
maintenir la notion de progrès merci
beaucoup Corinne pelichon